one of my favorites uh i've known this
man for quite some time last time i saw
him was at the
nfl honors at the super bowl feels like
19 years ago
um but uh it was great to see this guy
then and it'll be great to see him in
wild mountain time
available in theaters and on demand this
very friday december 11th
with emily blunt jamie dornan
christopher walken and this man
jon hamm how are you john hey-o
[Music]
nice kia that was amazing john it's what
i do for a living
you know what i mean it's what i do for
a living you do it well
tee it up and set it up and do all that
stuff and
i guess it's a good segue for me to
promote my new job
defensive coordinator for the new york
times
john hamm is going to be bringing the
heat
when appropriate not say you know
when the heat was just brought the only
thing that could beat you
is to be beat deep on a double move that
you fight on somehow i don't know i'm
sure you that's been dissected
backwards and forwards yeah he's got
football on tuesday afternoons
the world is upside down you guys they
literally like
that you have to think about it john if
the jets had taken all 11 of their
defenders
and lied them down on the goal line
had to you know win the game toad just
in case henry ruggs would have had to
maybe trip over them you know and
he would have been out again you know
what i mean just that that would have
been a better
defensive posture i think it was a
curious call
uh it begs the question how bad do you
want
a quarterback from clemson
well i can answer that question john
badly very very badly yes
yes i don't know the world's upside down
you said it correctly rich it seems like
the super bowl which was less than a
year ago right
like it was uh in the 40s i know
but that was a fun night i mean it's not
your first nfl honors rodeo
as well uh you know you've been around a
lot of people of note in your lifetime
john but that
that is pretty cool to be back there
right for an nfl it's always it's always
cool to meet those guys and
especially when you when you get the
like young guys and how wide-eyed and
amazed they all are and
um weirdly enough zeke elliot who i had
never
met before although we did go to the
same uh high school
uh i i got to meet him uh that night
and uh and to ask him how it felt to be
the second most popular person from our
high school
and how do you take that one how do you
think you got to chuckle out of that
one that came up on a championship so i
feel like uh we're good
now did was that a courtesy chuckle or
did he really find that funny do you
think john
uh i'm gonna go with he really thought
it was funny okay
so i remember back out of the
conversation very quickly
yes because i remember kyler murray was
back there peyton manning was back there
i mean everyone was back we had
far far was there it was like it was
right it's such a good it feels like
you're kind of crashing
a really cool uh summer camp reunion of
a camp that you
have no business and then
and then it's time for you to actually
you know uh go out on stage
and you're like really do i have to go
because you just don't want to leave
that room
you know it's it's so cool back there
also the weird thing is like as soon as
like the skate like going out and
presenting
yes that's when i'm like i feel fine
doing this and that's when all of the
athletes start going like
i don't i'm not really comfortable
talking in front of people
and you're like well let's don't worry
about it i i got this part give you the
part where you throw the ball and you're
blocking exactly and
jon hamm here on the rich eisen show do
you i
ask you this i forget are you a
cardinals guy like still in arizona
or because of the st louis thing or do
you have a football team is it the
broncos or something like that i'm
trying to remember
what you told me once i confront i
confronted roger goodell once
okay uh as we've all imagined in our
minds
um and uh i said you know you've
successfully taken two franchises from
my city uh
and i want i want retribution so my
retribution is simply rooting for the
chiefs
i've i've uh i've just pushed it to the
to the west side of the state
uh most people don't realize this but
kansas city is in fact in missouri
and uh i can uh i can do that with
impunity
uh and the fact that they're super good
right now
has nothing to do with my allegiance
that's what i'll say is like did you
make that maneuver
you know when i mean you got to make
sure here
it didn't hurt that mahomes exploded
right around the time i was decided to
become a chiefs fan uh it certainly
didn't hurt
and who doesn't like andy reid i mean
come on i know
i guess uh it's a combination well you
know and again your
your saint louis uh credentials are
rock solid john there's no doubt about
that and i'd like to bring up uh
one thing that we talked about the last
time here on the new audience for the
show here on peacock is you
rocking a st louis cardinals baseball
hat
to a world series game at wrigley field
um
and how did that go for you john that
night
well it was a controversial statement
for some people i i didn't i didn't
really mean anything by it other than
i certainly wasn't going to wear a cubs
hat i needed a hat
yes and i wasn't going to wear an indian
i mean what what had i
explained it to quite a few cubs fans on
the day
when you know like like most things it's
easy to get
your dander up when you're screaming
anonymously on the radio or
or in a comment section but when you
speak to somebody in person you
generally
you know the cooler heads prevail so in
person when i spoke to people
well of course you're gonna wear your
cardinal fan that's fine we're very
happy
for you with the exception of one very
particular cubs fan
who took my hat off and threw it over
the uh over the wall
and into the alley of the bar that we
were all in and that cubs fan was bill
murray
okay now then uh when did you
when did you realize it was bill murray
the it and did you have like a flash of
indignity and like there's
no
uh it was after game five which they won
and we were uh myself joel murray who
was a co-star on mad men
uh with me and a very good friend of
mine uh as well as
you know the murray the murray clan runs
pretty deep although they did lose their
their oldest brother this year rest in
peace um
they they run about six or seven
siblings in that family there's brian
doyle
yes uh there's a joel there's uh there's
several murrays
um chad michael i'm not sure if he's
related
um great reference john
so um i believe one of their sisters was
there that night it was a party it was
very exciting christilius was there
eddie better was there
chicago royalty was out in uh
force that night and i was there uh with
one of my managers who's from the south
side of chicago
another friend of mine uh who flew in to
see the game
and uh and so it was a very celebratory
evening and i had uh i was wearing my
hat and
people were singing and karaoke and
dancing were all in sort of the back
outside space of a bar right near
wrigley
and billy who i have met on several
occasions and
i wouldn't say that i know well but i
definitely know enough to say hi
uh said hi in a sort of a
jubilant dancing excited way
and at the same time said get this
hat off your head and plucked it off the
top of my head
and kind of reverse tossed it
over the wall into the alley and i
watched it sort of sail into the night
and i thought well i guess i'll never
see that
again and i followed it down and i
looked to the left
on the wall that he had thrown it over
and there was a door
to the alley so i just opened the door
and i
took three steps out and picked my hat
up off the ground and put it back on my
head
now that's fandom sir yes
the end of the end of the story is even
better because
up to maybe a year or so later and now
now this whole story has been you know
printed in the chicago tribune yes
john hamm is punking the cubs by wearing
a hat from the cardinals that's from the
none of this i knew i just wore the hat
because i thought it was cool i got it
on a photo shoot
um so i'm hosting an event for
the make-a-wish foundation of illinois
based in chicago now i'm not from
illinois i'm from st
louis but there's a friendly rivalry
yada yada here we are
so part of the thing is a live auction
and so one of one of the things was i
would i said i would
i would auction off the hat yes that i
wore
to the world series you can blow it up
like the steve bartman ball you can run
it over with a truck
you can give it to your friend from st
whatever you want to do yes it's all for
the kids i'm very happy to do it
and i think it's sold for like five or
six thousand dollars so somebody had
in the in the audience had a real grudge
against that hat
or is wearing it today i don't know
so i guess the moral of the story is is
that if your hat
gets thrown off of your head uh by
anybody it could be comedy film royalty
television comedy film royalty or anyone
and it's thrown
into some sort of chicago uh
street water stream pick up the hat put
it back on your head because
it could make some money for charity
right john exactly
you never the moral of the story is you
never know
you never know that's the story and we
give you a clap for that it's
it's wonderful it's it's wonderful
especially since again
the reason why you wore it is
functionality you needed a hat
you know what i mean what are you gonna
go to a baseball game and where uh uh
unless you're going to a patriots game
you could do that and fire off a you
know
exactly a cannon or something like that
i would never do it
jon hamm here uh on the rich eisen show
i i don't know how to make the turn i'll
just make it anyway wild mountain time
is available in theaters and on demand
this friday
christopher walken that had to be
something i know you're not in a lot of
scenes with him but
that had to be quite something for you
to be on a set with uh
with some royalty on that front john
yeah we shot this movie in uh in ireland
in county mayo ireland in a small town
near a small town called
balina um which weirdly enough
is where joe biden's family is from
back back in the days so they were very
excited about recent events
um but it was an amazing opportunity to
get to work without only chris walken
but a guy named john patrick shanley who
wrote and directed the film who's
written such films as moonstruck
uh joe versus the volcano
um he's a multi you know he's he's one
of my kind of
heroes of of of stage and screen
from a writing and directing standpoint
and i and i've i just
wanted to meet him and work with him
forever and it turned out the feeling
was mutually offered me
this part in this in this movie and i
thought this a this is awesome
because i get to work on the thing then
b this is awesome because i don't have
to do an irish accent
so it was a win-win for me
but then i read the script and it's
based on a play called outside mowing
guard that i had seen a long time ago
um that i really loved and and i i
thought he did a great job of adapting
the script and it's
it's basically like you know it's an
old-fashioned movie it's like a
it's a fable it's a love story that
takes place in kind of outside of time
in this magical part of ireland
that's really quite um fanciful and
beautiful
and funny and fun but really it's just
it has it's one of those rare things in
in the in the
uh in the community today that just has
no
snark it's just purely it wears it's
hard on its sleeve and it's proud to do
it and so
uh i've seen the film it's very good uh
emily blunt and jamie jordan who play
the sort of star-crossed lovers at the
center of the story
are phenomenal in it um dearborn malloy
and
chris walken as you mentioned play the
the the mother
and father uh of the uh the two
uh leads mentioned previously and
they're phenomenal and then it's cast
with
an amazing sort of cast of characters
that barry mcgovern is in it who people
will recognize from a lot of
giant patrick shannon's movies um it's
just a beautiful film and it's like
for the holiday season for what we've
all been through for 2020
it is the perfect sort of tonic
to when you sit down on the couch or
since no one can go to movie theaters or
maybe i don't know if you rent a movie
theater
uh but if you sit down on the couch and
load it up it is
it's an hour and a half of your time
that you'll be very happy to
you'll feel good i think we all need
available in theaters if if
uh you can or on demand this very friday
december 11th
jon hamm this is uh this is as
delightful as i hoped it would be and i
knew it would be quite frankly
thank you jonathan oh pleasure have a
happy holiday it's like
you before then my love to you family um
and uh and uh i don't know go jets
you better say that since you're the new
defensive coordinator john i mean you
got to be all in
you got to be all in if this is good
you're going to happen
when i take over this defense they're
not a bad team by the way
when i take over this defense and start
running it with some credibility
i'm going to get fired at the end of the
season because we're gonna end up losing
trevor we're gonna we're gonna win out
yep we're gonna bust out a bunch of
people's uh
suicide leagues and i'm gonna get fired
well because we're gonna lose the number
one pick there you go there you go the
voice of two all or nothings
uh saying he's uh it's nothing
all or nothing that's it there you go
it's nothing is what john hamm is saying
thanks for the call john you take care
you got it great talking with you
right back at you that's jon hamm wild
mountain time everybody check it out in
theaters and on demand this friday
december 11th
that's great he is so funny man amazing
god he cracks me up
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here